Hello and them perhaps you've taken what's called a Myers Briggs type indicator,
an Nbti the test which gives you the four letters that describe your
psychological preferences.
It's good to understand what these four letters mean.
But to do that you have to understand what the cognitive functions upon which
they are based mean.
So what are the cognitive functions?
Well,
long story short,
Carl Young,
a famous Swiss psychologist,
specular that we humans have four main psychological functions for how we see
the world and each of them has an extroverted and introverted type in four of
these are dominant in us.
While even though we use all eight extroverted or introverted feeling
extroverted or introverted thinking,
extroverted or introverted,
intuition and extroverted or introverted sensing.
So have your main for cognitive functions you will have two which are
extroverted and which are introverted.
But what do these even mean?
Well,
let's get into explaining that.
Starting with feeling integrated,
feeling abbreviated.
F I introverted are feelers tend to navigate the world with a strong system of
values and a focus on what is right and wrong.
They tend to inspect other's actions this side if they are morally acceptable,
and I don't mean to make them come off as rigid,
Fr dominance are usually pretty easy going,
but if if they sense that their value system has been broken significantly
enough,
they will it have a strong urge to react to that.
They tend to prefer to express themselves with feelings and actions rather than
words.
Extroverted feeling abbreviated,
f e similar,
but it has to do with more of a focus on the feelings and intentions of other
people around them.
Effie dominance can be very leader,
likes are good at maintaining group values and goals and adjusting themselves to
accommodate others.
They can be very good teachers,
peacemakers and caregivers,
but can also become too invested in certain people causing them to try to fix
their undesirable qualities.
Now for thinking introverted thinking,
abbreviated TEI,
introverted thinking has to do with organizing,
analyzing and evaluating things to fit it into the big picture or to understand
the core of things.
T I dominance tend to appreciate conciseness and objective reasoning as a part
of their goal to understand the world around them.
They often look for inconsistencies and arguments or actions or flaws in systems
or theories and may mentally try to improve things to reach the best of all
possibilities.
Extroverted thinking,
abbreviated Tbi.
Again,
similar to extroverted thinking,
but I suppose the main difference here is an introverted thinking tends to focus
on how the world works.
Extroverted thinking you could say is about a desire to make the world around
them work.
They're very good at organizing and efficiency and when they decide to
accomplish a goal,
they're very good at finding ways to do it and generally,
well,
they may come off as Bossy,
but in reality what they're doing is trying to organize the world and to what
they believe is necessary for the world to work,
not for intuition.
Introverted intuition,
abbreviated and I introverted intuiters are very good at noticing patterns or
signs and they're good as not only finding relationships between things,
but also how these relationships fit into the larger picture.
Making them good at solving problems and planning for the future.
When an eye dominance discover a link between two things.
They often experience a Eureka moment,
which is them fulfilling their own desire to find the links between a certain
subject or their environment around them.
Extroverted intuition,
abbreviated an e.
Extroverted intuiters are good at finding relationships between things as well,
but also entertaining multiple interpretations at once in finding hidden meaning
behind the things they're good at.
Brainstorming new ideas.
It can reach strong conclusions about their ideas very well.
However,
living in the world of possibilities can make extroverted intuitors unsure of
their conclusions or can cause them to have trouble sometimes making up their
minds.
Sensing introverted sensing abbreviated as I introverted sensing has to do with
remembering the experiences you've had in detail and using them to compare them
to other experiences you've had to find similarities and them introverted
sensors are good at drawing on the past to deal with the present or near future.
They pay attention to detail and use this to recognize things quickly.
For example,
this can range from interpret.
Sensors have been an easier time recognizing the similarities between two movies
or recognizing a pattern that may lead eventually to something destructive
because it has in the past,
extroverted sensing,
abbreviated s e extroverted sensing has to do with experiencing the world around
you in the form of sights,
sounds,
sensations,
etc.
Extroverted sensors are good at noticing data from experiences and are good at
making practical use of what they know.
They also seek to understand the world around them and have it as desire to
participate in it,
leading them to enjoy activities such as sports or outdoor activities.
So those are the age cognitive functions.
Yes,
some of them may seem kind of similar and again,
it's not immediately obvious how they match up with your Myers Briggs
personality type.
So let's take a look at that and we'll use a few types as example.
We'll start with my type the I n,
t p.
So as an INTP I and perhaps you have these four main cognitive functions are
primary or what's called the dominant is introverted thinking.
Tbi are secondary or auxiliary is extroverted.
Intuition and e are third or tertiary is introverted sensing.
And our fourth or inferior function is extroverted.
So basically I ntps lead with a desire to analyze,
categorize and evaluate their world,
followed by an e,
which is the desire to interpret relationships and make connections and draw
possibilities followed by introverted sensing,
which has to do with drawing on past experiences to connect them to current
events followed by extroverted feeling,
which is used in a concern for the emotions and desires of other people around
them and for social harmony.
The other four unmentioned functions are still there of course,
but like I said,
they're called the shadow functions.
They still hold sway over the INTP thinking pattern.
You will still use them,
but it is not as common and it's not a preferred way of doing things.
In fact,
most types will prefer to use their first three functions and may have to
develop their inferior function and their chateaux functions over time with
maturity.
To take another type,
the ees FFP,
the ESF p leaves with extroverted sensing,
which is experiencing the world around them,
followed by introverted feeling,
which is valuing and considering important,
followed by extroverted thinking,
which is organizing their environment around them,
followed by introverted,
intuiting,
looking into the future,
trying to bring things together and understand the effects of things.
So I hope you have a better understanding of this now and here are the 14 other
types along with their cognitive functions.
So I hope I've covered the subject.
Yeah.
In depth.
Um,
in the future I may do a video explaining the 16 Myers Briggs types and their
habits,
but for now,
you may find more videos on many other subjects on my channel.
And to keep up with these future videos,
I would invite you to subscribe to fire of learning.
It's like if we're watching.